what's happening you bad [__]
the joint is brought to you by
freeze pipe listen
you want some strong [__] lungs then
here's what you got to do you got to
exercise you got to get plenty of sleep
you got to stop using old broken dirty
ass bongs that you've had since [__]
kindergarten be a man and use a bong
that's smooth
on every [__] hit it doesn't hurt
your throat they're tremendous
i'm talking about the freeze pipe bong
the little [__] pipe bomb there they
are tremendous smoking weed does not
have to hurt your [__] lungs with
freeze pipe you can get an ice cold hit
every time it's like i used to live in
colorado i would take a scoop of snow
put in the [__] bong and spark it
voila tremendous here's how freeze pipe
works the pipe comes with a detachable
chamber you freeze it beforehand when
you're ready to [__] see the devil
you [__] and the smoke passes through
the frozen part it cools down the smoke
as you inhale it's like putting ice
cubes in the bong 100 [__] better
when you finish you put it right in the
refrigerator that's it it's non-toxic
and it freezes faster than water and it
stays frozen longer
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds of degrees your throat will
thank you whether you hit a pipe the
bubbler like i have here the bong or the
dab they got it all over that freeze
pipe you could smoke it
freeze pipe makes it you understand me
now listen
the joint listeners go to freezepipe.com
again that's freezepipe.com listen even
if you don't want to buy it just go look
at one of these [__] bungs and how
they work whether it's the bubbler the
bong or the pipe go to freezepipe.com
and pressing code joey i'm gonna give
you ten percent off your first order
this pipe is [__] tremendous if you
look if you like to do bong hits for
jesus this pipe's going to get you into
heaven do me a favor go to
freezepipe.com
press and co joey
and save 10 percent you're going deep
into the [__] murky waters with
freezepike.com the joint is also brought
to you by draftkings listen
come on guys how many times i got to
talk to you about this this weekend live
from [__] new york no it's not
saying i live [__] those punks it's
usman versus covington round two
[__] the nigerian nightmare and
chaos are gonna go [__] at it in the
octagon now listen close
i got an inside tip for you
[__] uncle joey loves you
during ufc 268 five dollars can net you
two hundred dollars with draftking
sportsbook did you hear that that's five
dollars connect you 200 with draftkings
sportsbook new customers just bet five
hours on either fighter and win 200
dollars and free bets
listen to me i love draftkings i know
it's a lot of competition out there but
between you and i draftkings is the best
they're safe
secure and reliable you could withdraw
your cash whenever they want and they
just don't cover the ufc their official
betting partner the ufc but they're also
the official betting partner of the nba
the nfl
listen saturday night you got frankie
edgar you got bobby green you got
aliquinta you got
gaiji against chandler you got come on
you got the nigerian nightmare against
covington and thursday night what do you
got you got the jets versus indy come on
guys friday night you got the nba this
is the time of the year when you thrive
on draftking sportsbook so do me a favor
download the draftking sports book right
now use promo code joey what does that
mean that means that when you bet five
dollars
on the ufc 268 main event you're going
to win 200 miles and free bets if your
fighter wins that's code joey this
saturday the 6th november at madison
square garden go to draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
part of the ufc now you got to be 21
older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado new customers only
minimum five hour deposit and one dollar
wager required here's the tricky one one
per customer don't be [__] cute and
show up on an alias i'll stab you in the
next restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem i sympathize call 1-800
gambler you don't need to be lurking
over here but if you're [__] straight
head over to draftkings right now and
let's win some [__] guitars
pressing code joey and let's get this
party started right now it's wednesday
tonight you either have [__] nba and
you're gonna go right tomorrow into the
nfl right into friday into the nba and
boom
you got [__] ufc and then you got
college basketball we got so much going
on on draftkings it'll make your head
spin the best casino out there whether
it's blackjack football blackjack poker
it all starts at draftkings download the
draftking sportsbook app
and enter code joey let's get this
[__] party started the joint is also
brought to you by
stamps.com if you're looking for ways to
skip the post office and dodge all that
holiday traffic why not save time money
and [__] you're not going to get
covered on your neck let me tell you
something it sucks to go to the post
office you got to stand there people
breathing on you
there's always [__] three filipinos
instead of 10 of them where the [__] is
the help at the post office they bring
stamps.com brings the services to the us
post office right to you
print the official postage
for any letter any package anywhere you
want to ship
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com it's like taking the
stairs when the elevator is right
[__] there why would you do that with
stamps.com you got exclusive discounts
on postage and shipping from usps and
ups once your mail is ready you just
schedule a pickup or drop it off no more
traffic no more lines take the confusion
out of shop other shipping if you're not
with stamps.com you're [__] slipping
especially for the holidays i've been
with stamps.com me and my wife for close
to [__] 15 years they're tremendous
you'll never go to the post office again
sign up for the special promo code joey
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial free postage and a digital
scale
no long long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code joey stamps.com
never go to the post office again
[Music]
where's my [__] lighter now it's time
to get this party started is to join on
a wednesday morning november 3rd
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's wednesday the
third of [__]
november november's pushing on guys
that's it
it's the final [__] run of the year
three weeks from tomorrow you got
thanksgiving and then what is it four
weeks after that i won't even give you a
[__] chance you [__] wake up you
go to the store and you're hearing
[__] and so this is christmas and
you're like what the [__] it was just
july i was at a baseball game sweating
profusely it's a great day i was uh i'm
still writing a book guys listen
the movie came out
nothing has happened for me i have not
heard from my theatrical agents and i
don't give a [__] i'm not mad or
anything but it's so funny that the only
thing i'm working on right now this has
given me a chance
to work on this book so i talk to her
we talk an hour and a half to an hour on
the phone four times a week this book is
moving
a lot [__] fast and i anticipated we
uh like i said
i cut out you know i would go on these
[__] ear beatings
and ever since i'm not high all the time
anymore now when i do the
the i look at the main [__]
diagram whatever the thing we did and
then
i simplify it i rewrite it and then i
tell her on the phone and we just go
back and forth
so the process has been great i'm really
happy to do this uh my niece is going
through some pictures i used to send her
mother pictures
for years when i was in colorado and a
couple weeks ago she told me she goes i
got a bunch of pictures of you
and some german shepherd and [__] i go
oh my god your mom saved those pictures
so she's getting all the pictures
together for the book and all that so
it's coming together
great and i gotta be honest with you
this thing was eating away at me
for seven [__] years i couldn't get
this done
erica has really [__] uh just
it's amazing when people know what the
[__] they're doing you know what i'm
saying like you next time your car
breaks and you're like i'll do it i go
on youtube that's great that's great but
when your car makes a weird noise don't
come [__] crying to me when people
know what they're doing they just go
right through something she said i've
learned more from her like i guys
after working with her i had to stop
writing
like that's how bad i am it's like when
i saw stan hope in 96 and i almost quit
comedy because i knew i'd never be so
good like as good as he was it's the
same [__] thing this chick
just simplifies it so we were doing the
chapter
i want to fill you guys on this chapter
real quick we were doing a chapter on
1998-99
and it was uh the four blocks that's
what the chapter is called it's kirsan
vista
sierra bonita and uh kirsan
and those are the four blocks from me
stanhope
mitch hedberg ralphie mayne josh wolflet
you know
and we're just going back and forth to
the chapter how we were all broke
uh ralphie was friends with jay moore
and jeff ross
that was the only hope we ever had of
getting a couple dollars like when they
came over if they chipped in 20 like we
would eat shipping like two or three
dollars and buy like a turkey so ralphie
could deep fry it or we would buy
[__] ralphie would deep fry a [__]
turkey in his backyard till seven in the
morning the thing would be smoking it
was it was just he couldn't
you know we were broke
now let's simplify this it was basically
at that time it was me
doug
ralphie
josh wolfe
myself
you know even mitch hedberg all of us
were broke the only guy that had money
any money was doug stanhope he had
gotten a 10 000 deal from hbo
and that money was probably gone you
know he would buy us all sodas and [__]
like that
but we were just
six or seven broke comics there were
some other comics in the neighborhood
that you don't know
they got out of the business so they
moved away
and it was just the life of a [__]
comic man it was just so weird to write
this this chapter we spent two days on
it and just talking about it and going
back and forth
it was like the highlight of my comedy
career like if i had to think
about the best time i had in the 30
years
it was 97 through 2000 right before i
met terry i mean when i met terry it was
great too
but it was just me alone
it was bare bones i was you know like
when you have a girlfriend you're doing
something
it's like she helped me do it i was
living with her you know this i was
living in a car
i was sleeping on ralphie may's floor i
was living on josh wolf's couch you know
josh wolfe was living on a [__]
budget he had no money and three kids
ralphie had no money he was living on
[__] uh whatever gigs he didn't know
ralphie was making a lot more money than
me and josh wolfe at the time we were
broke you know we were just we were just
all we were looking to do was make rent
eat
and in my world pay child support i
wasn't looking to buy cars i wasn't
looking to buy clothes in fact i had to
decide between socks and underwear
what's more important like when you're a
broke comic you have to decide about
what do i have money to spend on socks
and underwear so i never wore underwear
i said [__] it if it's between socks and
underwear you can live without [__]
underwear but you can't live without
socks your sneakers will be all [__]
stinky and [__]
so
i would i didn't have underwear guys i
would just [__] live
i had maybe four pair of pants four
shirts a pair of sweats a couple
t-shirts and swimming shorts that
doubled as you know
shorts you know like they just doubled
they had no choice you know you didn't
have a pair of running sneakers you
never paint oh these are my stage
sneakers no one shoe fits all that shoe
went to the gym with you that shoe went
on the stage with you that shoe if you
put on a suit you had to put sneakers on
because you didn't have shoes
we were that [__] broke
but i never
can remember myself being that happy
because we were making it happen
i was auditioning was i booking no but i
wasn't expecting to book it was my first
two years here yeah you expected the
book because you're a [__] idiot but
not because you're any good you're like
i got that no you didn't you went and
[__] blew it you know i had nothing
going on except whatever i was making
going on
so all i had going on was a notebook
and the comedy store and the occasional
spots at the improv and the [__]
laugh factory but my life was at comedy
store and dog when those we got 15 a set
from the comedy store so if you got if i
host if i hosted
and did four spots that's 85 a week
and i was happy
85 a week was like ten thousand like
when i would pick up that eighty five
dollars for comedy
for my comedy
come on
that was a feeling that you couldn't
even like i made eighty-five dollars
this week doing comedy i don't give a
[__] about the world i don't give a [__]
about taxes i don't give a [__] about
anything all i care about is getting on
stage getting better and finding a place
to sleep doesn't even have to have a
blanket
that's how bad bones we were we were
[__] animals and you know what she
asked me at the end of
the [__] thing she goes joey from
listening to this i mean part of it
sounds great
but the other the other part of it
sounds like you were struggling i go
let me tell you something that was the
most fun i ever had in my career
was that little [__] time period when
we were broke we were just going to
ralphies
eating
we would buy a bottle of like the
cheapest vodka
like at night the cheapest vodka
and he would
we'd make
bloody marys i never drank a bloody mary
in my life i don't ever want to drink a
bloody mary in my life but let me tell
you something [__] when you're broke
you'll drink that [__] bloody mary
with cocaine i was doing bloody mary
with cocaine i didn't know if it was
blood coming out of my nose or tomato
juice i didn't know what the [__] was
coming out of my [__] nose but let me
tell you something man when i think
about those times like when i got off
the phone with her i looked at the
outline
and i'm like i'm saving this [__]
outline i'm gonna frame this [__]
outline and sell it because
that was the best time of my [__]
life
we had the sunset grill the song the
eagles sing about we had the guitar
center we had the flower shop
where uh
what's his name would buy flowers from
marilyn monroe
we had the creepy comic book store uh
nuclear comics whatever that thing and
that was our day we just went into those
places like we had money like we'd walk
in hey what's going on and we looked
through [__] we used to go into the
guitar center and [__] just play the
drums and play the guitars the techs
would come over and let us do [__] and
they would like [__] after 10 minutes
they would just walk away we'd just be
making noise it sounded like metallic
unplugged if they were drunk and
[__] and blind like we were just
horrible but that that area was our
[__] playground
there was a hotel there on the corner of
the sahara or something and there was a
pimp in there that would get his dick
sucked i mean we would go watch him and
then he would throw the condoms into the
pool and the pool was green and all you
would see were these big mag
magnum cobbles splitting the [__]
thing that was our entertainment there
was a gas station that i would sit by
the corner and wait for the owner to
come out and pump gas because i would
run in get a bag of chips in the soda
and then put my hand behind the counter
and take a pack of marlboro lights when
he would come in there would just be i
only had a dollar for the water that was
a dollar for the soda i would go in
there every time i was broke and every
time he'd be pumping gas i'd run to the
[__] gas station grab a water bag
that was my breakfast i lived off of
wendy's
99 cents cheeseburger junior and
and a bowl of chili at that time i would
get a bowl of chili for 99 cents a 99
cents junior burger and fries that's
what we had three dollars me and josh
wolfe or josh wolfe would make turkey
burgers but my point being
how no matter how broke i was no matter
if i had to sleep on the floor no matter
what was going on what adversity was
getting thrown at all of us we were
having the best time of our life
because we were doing it on our own
[__] time so if you're one of those
people that's thinking of becoming a
plumber or an electrician and there's
that cold period where you don't have
any money let me tell you something
get into it don't worry about that time
because you're not going to be broke you
have friends and you have people around
you you have other
uh acquaintances that are going through
the same [__] struggles and we just
made it work it just worked
while i was in it i didn't think i was
going to get out of it i i i was
thinking about it yesterday like
1999 i never thought i was going to get
out of being a feature act
fighting to be on the road and all that
[__] but years later things slowed up i
got a job but at that time right then in
none of us had money josh wolfe was
broke all of us
and we were just six guys helping each
other out you know every once in a while
josh wolf would have extra money he'd
make his turkey burgers with mushrooms
and onions and [__] and that turkey
burger was like a [__] lobster tail
back then so
if you're ever thinking of switching
careers or getting something where
you're gonna be money's gonna be tight
for a while
don't let it get to you go for it you
know why
because you're never going to forget
that time that's what's going to make
you
a better whatever the [__] you want to
do in my case it may be a better comment
going through that time period because i
know i went through it and i'll never
have to be there again and it was just a
great time doing it so
when i look at my career and i go yeah
man i struggled and [__] let me tell you
something
that struggle was fun as [__] when the
struggle ended is when it became work
and that's why i'm not doing it anymore
because it became work but it was a fun
[__] struggle and uh
if you ever have the opportunity to look
forward to it look forward to it's going
to make you a strong [__]
like i told him
uh two nights ago i was in the
you know in the basement listening the
[__] music
and i stumbled upon a supreme song
keep me hanging on by the supremes i
think it's a great [__] song
it was uh
out of motown's biggest height you know
and i know a lot of you people go to
supreme what are you thinking joey jesus
christ
no i've liked the supreme since i was
13. my mother listened to him in a bar
and i like i like that motown sound you
know
when i was thinking about it i go
there's only one person
that would appreciate this music
and that's [__] dean del rey so i
called him up i go dean i'm listening to
the supremes and i thought of you
because dean's the student of the game
he likes all [__] music black white
chinese he'll find the beauty in it
so uh
out of respect for him today as guest
is my man dean doe rizzy we do our daily
little
listen no matter what podcast i'm on no
matter whether you guys like it or not
dean del rey rudy sarzo there's a
handful of guys
that come on my podcast between 90 and
120 days because i miss them sick little
beyond soon you know people like that i
miss these guys so i hope you enjoy it
dean del rey
[Music]
oh [__]
welcome to the [__] joint
[__]
there he is the [__] star of the
sopranos what's going on the star i got
shot in the [__] head by uh by alec
baldwin
that [__] shot me with a prop
gun that [__]
if you see me getting shot in the head
you could tell i didn't know nobody knew
what was going on they just shoot me in
the head that's [__] uh alec baldwin
that was driving on a bicycle
eating a bag of potato chips with the
[__] prop gun in his pocket
little clam dip and everything what's
going on brother
oh man you know just back from vegas
after 14 shows out there at the comedy
cellar that's about it that looked
[__] great i was looking at your
pictures and you brought the dog with
you you had the whole [__] family out
there didn't you yeah i just kept
thinking that joey go don't bring your
[__] dog everywhere [__] dog jesus
christ i went trick-or-treating the
other day
40 [__] kids and the one guy says to
me hold on our friend is coming he's
running late
and he shows up with a [__] 90-pound
dog and with trick-or-treat
and the whole time i'm like you know
there's always that one jerk off that
tries to take attention from the kids
it's about the kids leave the [__]
dog at home they put like a superman
costume on him or some [__] the [__] is
wrong with you with a superman costume
[__] dog
and the dogs are half a frag to boot
like if he was a tough dog or a pit bull
with a beard
then i'd be in but he's a [__]
fruitcake the dog
yeah like you know i want to see a
[__] animal missing an eye that's the
one you put a superman [__] suit on
somebody hit him in the stick when he
was a puppy or some [__]
yeah yeah hell yeah hell yeah there's
joey man
what's happening brother
oh man i [__] you know i was in vegas
and i had this guy on josh freeze who's
one of the biggest drummers on the
planet i played with nine inch nails and
weezer
and uh devo oh everyone and so he's like
hey i'm playing with sting i have him on
the podcast and he goes we're going to
be
doing a dress rehearsal wednesday at
caesars come by so i go down to the
theater and it's just me and like 10
people watching sting and this whole
band just [__] kill it dude two feet
away he's like fist bumping me and [__]
how does thing sound
dude he sounded unreal 70 years old he
looked great he sounded great they're
playing some great police class classics
like walking on the moon you know oh man
you know a couple weeks ago on patreon i
gave out
synchronicity
as one of the albums of the week and i
went three years ahead
because i was like you know what this is
an album that people need to listen to
like you wouldn't go to the store and
buy the police unless you're a police
fan now
i don't walk around with police shirts
do i you don't say no [__]
they got like three albums that aren't
good they're deadly
yeah
like you two i'm not a youtube fan okay
i'm not a youtube fan i like them
but when it comes to [__]
that one album they put on 87
oh man
there's just some albums that people
need to [__] have in their life and i
feel bad when they don't have that
particular album those like eat a peach
is a necessary album
you know [__] uh super [__]
breakfast over america yeah it's a [__]
you know i'm saying like there's just
certain albums that you have to have
certain books you're not a fan of that
offer but they they knocked it out of
the park on that particular
so i get i don't like sting as a human
being i have my issues with him really
yeah but he broke up the world's
greatest [__] trio yeah
over his [__] ego
yeah you know so him there's like two or
three guys him and
roger waters when it comes to me they
fall into that
you ruined one of the greatest things
pink floyd and the [__] police yeah
when it comes to music two of the
greatest [__] genres they're
phenomenal yeah and the thing is it's so
[__] hard it takes a million things
in the world to line up for a band to be
super group you know you gotta fight you
gotta meet each other then you gotta you
know get into a studio write songs
record then the people gotta like you
and when it all happens and then one
guy's like i'm out of here it's like
dude you know how [__] hard it is to
do that we need that you know it's like
a mona lisa yeah you can't they don't
come around every week
you know i i still remember going to see
the police and what i remembered vividly
i saw the police early on yeah same
early like eighth grade type [__] and
then i saw him again in 81 or something
82. right yeah 82 close to the machine
ghost in the machine i saw some and what
i can remember the most and you hate to
admit it to people
like you hate to say it because people
think you're a [__] nerd
that's stuart copeland whatever his
[__] name was yeah
he was hitting those drums
it's like missing persons when you go
see missing person she was hot she had
those little bite-sized titties and the
whole thing yeah but what i remember is
that little [__] bozio yeah
destroying those drums like you could
hear the joy you're like what's that
feeling in my back
it's the [__] drums going through my
spine
it's such a great feeling when you go
see a good drummer live like you don't
know what a good drummer is
until you go see that [__] live
and he starts dropping this [__] on you
so
yeah yeah his drummer josh freeze you
know he's uh i've known him for 35 years
and
this guy is a monster player man you do
yourself a favor and put in josh free's
nine inch nail drum videos like so he
set up these drum cams when he was in
nine inch nails and your [__]
hair is gonna blow back off of the
youtube video you're like that maxell
guy you know like ah
[__]
i mean that is how intense this guy is
on the drums he is a monster man
i love all that [__] you know i i loved
i love the bands that i love you know
like the judas priests and the allison
chains yeah we accept those
but then there's these other bands that
you're not a huge fan of you just pay
attention to them like i have my a-bands
and then i got my b bands who are my b
bands ufo
yeah uh
[__] the pretenders oh yeah the
police yeah b-52s are on a cusp
they're like first-team all-american and
second-team all-american i just got them
floating like in limbo but i think
they're great there's so many little
bands that you have like that you too
you know uh
just i love you
mac
oh he's not your favorite band but if
you put on rumors or tusk or whatever
the [__]
stevie nick solo or lindsey buckingham
solo i'm in i find it entertaining it's
not i'm not losing my [__] mind over
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
listen to it like the other night you
know what made me call you the other
night put you on the podcast what
i was listening to the [__] supremes
oh man
you know oh i i didn't know like when i
was a kid
my mom would listen to that music in the
bar when she would play cards the
supremes were on and i i don't know it's
like yeah they were chick band whatever
and then you hear him on the radio and
you're like whatever you know motown but
then you see like that documentary
oh man on motown on
the section and they wrote songs and you
watch
the [__] uh
rick james documentary he talks about
working at motown and yeah getting in
there with diana ross and stevie wonder
like when stevie wonder was on fire
and then when i was funny you mentioned
the soprano when i was in new york city
one sunday night
i worked but i wrapped early and i went
to my you know when you get to your
hotel room you know what to do you turn
the tv on you throw the remote on the
bed
and you start you know you jump in the
shower you get your sweats on whatever i
was watching uh
motown's
tribute to barry gordy oh yeah killer
and diana ross was the host
i don't know what happened like the show
wasn't it didn't come out as planned
so diana ross had to take over the show
and i tell you what she was singing and
dancing and [__] [__] around and
she actually sat on his lap and sang him
a song
and that's the first time i realized how
[__] talented
she really [__] was oh man but when
you hear like uh keep me hanging on
yeah
oh my god the [__] guitars on there
her voice her voice is of an angel in
that [__] jam
i mean she really has a great voice on
that it's uh
i love talent
oh god yeah right it's amazing when you
watch somebody talented and you go wow
that person is very [__] talented at
what he's doing
your dick gets hard
my dick gets hard you know
i mean when you and i were in detroit we
did that casino i got up early and
popped an uber over to uh you know
motown to hitsville there usa the
historic house where they had the
recording studios just a little box
that's basically a garage and you're
like whoa this is where all those songs
were recorded and then next door is
where they wrote them it was like
hitsville you know and then they they
then they kept growing and they got
another uh house next door to that where
they taught the dance moves and then
they got another house next to that
where they made the outfits and and
everything it was wild to see and the
the history in that place floored me and
it was sold out and i was like oh you
understand i do a huge podcast i
i gotta get in here i've got to see this
and the lady rolled me in man it was
great
oh man you know that david rutherford
the temptations that guy is a god to me
and i'll watch that garbage little uh
vh1 temptations film every time it's on
[__] hours five [__] hours when
they stop at the woman's house and eat
and she cooks for them and [__] every
time they're in town i'm in just i watch
it too it's always on uh
that champ vh1 yeah it's always on vh1
it's on once a week the temptations or
the jacksons yeah and those dudes that
played the guys were like when you look
at it you go like oh that's him i mean
those guys killed at those actors
bro the dude who played david ruffin
unbelievable park the dude who played
eddie kendricks
knocked it out of the park i think i got
to be honest with you like
i love black sabbath i love led zeppelin
i love van halen
but a powerful [__] group is the
temptations oh my god the best
translations were [__] powerful when
you think about when i think about
powerful bands i think about
the temptations there's one other band
that was just in the tip of my tongue
that's a soul band like earth winning
fire oh earthquake fire they put a show
on that was [__] tremendous and they
were great musicians
and you go and you're kind of [__]
entertained you're like i was listening
to i'll tell you what i put on two weeks
ago
and it was [__] phenomenal the funk
the best of the commodores oh on youtube
and i was i just was writing something i
had [__] to do how to send bills
and i put on the best of the commodores
brick house all that [__] those songs he
wrote that he gave to kenny rogers oh i
was thinking about that period with him
how hot he was hello
oh is it me you're looking for
and the blind girl's like no i don't see
a dick no you're not supposed to see a
dick you're blind
i remember when i was i was taking
singing lessons that was the one that
had me sing every week you know the old
lady on the piano [__] let's give this
one a shout again
hello
is it me you're looking fun i'm all shy
in sixth grade and i wonder where y'all
know
you know
she said he was on [__] fire too like
people really don't understand when
musicians
go on fire like i was raised during
elton john's fire
like that [__] him it was like
him versus paul mccarthy when i was
growing up paul will come out with silly
little love songs [__] elton john
would say take this [__]
philadelphia freedom and john would turn
i mean paul mccartney would turn around
we'd live and let die and elton john
would say take this [__]
you know your song you know yeah alton
john was on fire when i was a [__]
kid
fire and then people liked him and then
they found that he was gay yeah and
people like [__] that gay dude and i'm
like [__] him is right i'm gonna keep
listening to him give me the [__]
albums i love i got goodbye yellow brick
road from somebody
no i love ellen john i [__] love
elton john i'm doing a whole my whole 10
minute closer is about
people who are homophobic or racist but
they'll watch football and go see elton
john i'm like [__] those people you know
what i mean no nba finals for you ever
you know what i mean i'm not racist or
homophobic when i see a gay guy singing
i [__] love it i love you all there's
gay dudes i don't give a bo what was the
other guy when we were kids
i like that freddie mercury
yeah freddie mercury was bad to the ball
and i listen
if you don't think i knew rob halford
was gay from the first time i saw that
[__] in november of 79
in other words you got another thing
coming all right because well you grew
up in the suburbs if you didn't know he
was gay that's all there is to it i
[__] love when i saw rob half who was
gay i'm like this [__] is gay
the first time i saw him he had a whip
in his hand yeah
listen
yeah there's two times when it's time to
run when you see a gay guy with a whip
or you see a gay guy with a whistle that
means your asshole's about to get busted
you understand me so when i saw him with
the whip i was like oh my god i'm like
wait a second he ain't gonna whip me
with this [__] thing let me enjoy
this show i was dead by myself yeah and
i remember going home going yeah he's
gay but that's got nothing to do with me
yeah that's got nothing to do with me
i'm into his music i'm not homophobic i
don't give a [__] he's [__] gay sing
it with that sperm breath remember we
were kids everybody kept saying that rod
stewart oh yeah
in san francisco everybody had a friend
that was dead yeah my friend was in the
hospital room when they brought
[__] rods to it and they pumped the
stomach full of good nine ounces of
sperm he blew eight guys get the [__]
out of here that was the one about
richard gere that he was at the hospital
and they took a mouse out of his ass in
san francisco where's the [__]
affidavit let me see the [__]
affidavit let me see the mouse holding
on to his nose i know if i was a mouse
and they put me up somebody's ass
i really have some [__] anti-covert
nose strips
i don't understand how something like
that takes traction too because that
[__] myth went across the world i
mean that's way before there's no
internet he barely had a home phone and
it was like dude you hear about rod
stewart it wasn't on the radar the dj
didn't come in this
rod just drank 12 ounces of sperm and
he's getting a stomach that it just you
were at the locker and the guy's like
you hear about rod last night at the cow
palace and you're like what oh yeah they
had to pump his stomach
how did that [__] get traction joey
how did that get tracked
it went for years i felt [__] crazy
and i got sick of it like i saw richard
key in the city and let me tell you at
the time when i saw richard i wanted to
beat him up
because every chick i was in love with
wanted to suck richard gear's dick they
wanted nothing to do with me so i had a
personal vendetta for richard gere yeah
and i saw him when then i'm like this is
my night to kill him but he had people
around him and [__] like that he didn't
look gay yeah and then i saw office and
the gentleman i gave him a pass i go you
know what he's a good dude let me give
him a pass and me and richard have been
tight ever since i've never met him but
we've been tight ever since i got
nothing against him and i don't give a
[__] if they found the mouse in his ass
with scotch tape on his fingers
what's that got to do with me and my
love for his films i don't give a [__]
one of my favorite tvs one of the
funniest shows of all time
was that gay show on nbc
greg whatever with the [__] chick
darm is it darmian greg i never saw that
the other one the other one diamond greg
was a long [__] time ago
no uh the one on nbc and they just
rebooted it they brought it back oh
bosom buddies no it wasn't [__]
buddies
remember that yeah tom hanks he's from
boston buddies and then becomes the
biggest star in the world
will and grace oh i never saw it oh my
god that show is [__] funny that
little chick
all four of them are [__] funny the
two but the two that are supposed to not
be this it's the only show where the two
stars aren't funny
that's how we describe that show the two
[__] cast members are hysterical the
gay guy and the chick
i got to work with the chick
on that
what was that show late night that i did
mike children's hospital
yeah oh yeah i remember yeah i remember
that yeah like
a cartoon network yeah and i got to do
like a mafia episode me the dude from
the sports show with the rock
henry winkler the fonz was there i got
the special day with fonzie
megan
that my episode was [__] fire
sauragusa
from uh lorraine and shirley whatever
laverne shirley yeah yeah
it was fire my [__] episode it was
just a 15-minute episode
i think i worked on it for three days
and it was christmas week like we worked
on it till the 24th
so they threw like two day it was like
the perfect job
like i was telling somebody before that
my busy time is after thanksgiving and
before christmas
that's when i do my best acting that's
when if i'm gonna act that year i'll get
my best auditions and that was one year
that came in like on the 18th of
december and i shot the 19th 20th
straight to like the 23rd 24th and they
said for shooting we're going to give
you two extra days of production i was
like dawg i could use this money
looks like i'm snorting on new year's
eve thing yeah
and then i did another movie i did that
dark night promo oh yeah that was before
christmas and when i wrapped they had a
ralph lauren suit on me or something
that was really nice and i was
eyeballing it to steal it like i'm like
i'm gonna steal this suit for christmas
yeah you know [__] the grinch and i
[__]
as i was taking the suit i hung it up i
go i'm not gonna steal the suit what's
the matter with me joey you gotta get
away from that [__]
and i walked out the door lady goes hey
man
do you want to buy the suit
and i go how much for the suit she goes
we just bought it this morning give us
1200. wow whoa and i go can you take it
on my check and they were like hold on
and they talked for like five minutes
and they came back and they said hey man
you did a good job today merry christmas
wow
killer i still got the suit it's [__]
nine sizes too big it was when i was 400
pounds
i don't think you could hem this this
guy this like a curtain jack candy there
there's no we gotta we gotta ebay that
uncle joey's suit man we get some money
[__] suit from super batman the dark
knight and [__] like that man
well i've been having a lot of fun
lately
i haven't taken guitar lessons in like
three weeks we've both been busy he's
got bad weeks i'm still playing the
guitar
so what i started doing at night because
i got bored with just playing the guitar
by myself was doing what i did was as a
kid with an ad guitar
only with a guitar yeah yeah like i put
our song on like i my favorites uh like
i could actually play a little bit of
rotten apple
oh wow but not great i could just do the
rhythm section of it so i'll play over
the music and [__] like that but man
i've been getting discouraged lately
have you heard
have you heard cantrell's solo record
that just came out what i did here right
that it's [__] fire i have not heard
it at all but i heard
it's [__] fire we got brighton man oh
what a great [__] record dude
you know i fall in love with jerry
cantrell like he's great jerry
cantrell's one of those guys that keeps
sending you roses
yeah but you kind of don't like them
you're like
pass you know keep your [__] roses
every week he sends you a dozen roses
and you're like i'm not interested in
this [__] guy but i'll read the card
then one week you read the card one week
you smell them
one week you go oh what a pretty buzz
you know like there's all these [__]
things that make you want and then
eventually
you know after two years you kind of
like like i went to the north bergen
carnival where i'm from yeah
and i saw the kid he's
a young kid but he's the guy that turned
me on to alice in chains wow i was in
jersey doing comedy and he came to one
of the shows and he's like you know
allison chains like i know down in the
hole he's like nah you gotta [__] do
this you gotta do that you gotta listen
to this
and i saw him at the corner he's all
grown up now i'm like hey man thank you
for turning me on to alice and change
you get that exclusive [__]
god you were the one that was like take
that [__] ac dc old man music off
put on alice in chains i had like let
that be rock con or some [__] grandpa
rock i hang out with his older brother
and he was like take that [__] off you
gotta listen to alice in chains so he's
the i mean i was into them i was into
soundgarden i lived in seattle yeah i
knew who allison changed was but they
scared me
because the waitress at giggles
used to always invite me to go do heroin
up at capitol hill with the
singer yeah
the singer lane had like an open house
like you could just show up
put out your arm and somebody would hit
you with a [__] needle well i wanted
to meet him in the worst way like i
wanted to meet those guys you know sound
garden
uh pearl jam i saw
eddie veda one morning eating breakfast
on aokai
yeah outside of a diner he's eaten but
the glass was right there
no exaggeration he must have had 400
people
hitting on the glass
pushing other people and he's sitting
there just [__] laughing and then he
used to hang out with the pitcher rodney
mcdowell or one of those guys
guy on the mariners or something i don't
know if he was on the mariners i forgot
what team he was on
but when we used to hang out at the
comedy underground the comedy
underground is downstairs
from a bar yeah and that's where all the
baseball players hang out
that was a great
great [__] place where we used to do
comedy because
it was right down the block from the
stadium so the seahawks would be in
there
and the mariners would always be in
there i don't know how many nights i
went in there and saw
you know everybody upstairs you know so
i love the pacific northwest man
you know what man i'm not allowed back
in there
i was just up there dude
i'm going back uh
next week the 11th and 12th i'm doing
bend oregon of portland oregon
and uh you know i love it up there it's
got something up there i go up there
it's got a calming effect
well i heard somebody was just in
portland the last two weekends or three
weekends yeah and they made some
comments how rough the city is now and
uh there's some craziness going on
downtown you know in the city of
portland
but i got to be honest with you i cut my
comedy teeth in oregon you know i went
from boulder
to seattle and seattle is washington so
you do comedy in the surrounding states
and i tell you man bend is a [__]
tremendous town
and second only to boulder
wow really well yeah you haven't been to
bend no bend is baby boulder whoa
bench is where everybody from boulder
went
once it got too creepy and bolder like
boulder still has that essence but not
really like it yeah
money has taken over it you know they
don't give a [__] about the hippies
anymore yeah but ben doreeg and ben
oregon has a coffee shop that they do
comedy at yeah [__] music they got
everything in there i can't wait to go
and they got the last black master there
it's still open did you see that there's
a documentary on it though it's still um
some lady i guess owns it and still
licensed the name and it's the last
blockbuster so i shot the thing i saw
the thing i was like get the [__] out of
that blockbuster and come down and see
some comedy man this ain't the 80s yeah
i mean blockbuster blockbuster's still
up in portland one uh in bend the last
one in bend
i guess the documentary is called the
last blockbuster i haven't seen it yet
but i need to see that for comments
i love bend i love grant's pass
yeah [__] astoria oregon i've been to
when we ashland oregon
ashland oregon is where they do the
shakespeare festival every summer all
summer long
so the hotel does comedy once a week
and they don't put tvs in the hotel room
that's great you just sit in the hotel
room like what the [__] going on and
if you call the front desk you're like
listen man
i got up to my room and there's no tv in
here and the people will say we don't
put tvs in the room but if you want one
come down and get one they have the
little prism ones like the one i had in
prison a little black and white ones
with two channels and an am radio next
to it they have that so you got to watch
tv like on a little
i ate the biggest bag of dicks
in ashland oregon like one of those
life-saving sets that you're thinking
about getting a job at subway when you
get off the stage oh yeah work
yeah i used to [__] do comedy all
over oregon when i lived in seattle you
got this drive down there and it's great
i loved it portland
portland's a great city and that part
became like portland was a sleepy city
and the last 10 years they really picked
it up you and i did that helium up in
portland great i [__] love that room
that is great management great food
that's the first time and i'll be honest
with you guys here
i had ranch dressing
oh joey joey there and stress hater oh
[__] i gotta you gotta come clean with
the peeps you gotta come clean look
you're hurting here first let me tell
you something i'm a stoner guys okay
yeah
and i react to whatever i smoke
you ready for this mic these [__]
and let me tell you the story
it's in between no it's like the feature
actors up
so i'm saying yeah i could walk out
like when the feature act is up
everybody's nobody's paying attention oh
so i'd go for a walk so i would smoke a
joint
and then so i wouldn't get anxiety i
could that's the first club ever that me
smoking put on the alarm set off the
fire alarm they were not even pissed oh
my god the lights were going whoop whoop
felicia michaels was on stage she goes i
don't know what to do up here they were
[__]
and the fire department came back and
they're like what the jesus christ stop
smoking that [__] even they were cool
they were like don't worry about it
but i went down the hallway one day and
they have a table out there where the
waitresses put food down as like a
barrier in between the the people that
you're bringing the food to it's
expedited there and then she takes them
from there
so i'm walking out i'm high as [__]
okay this is what you get for being a
[__] so if you're a [__]
knock it
off i was walking by the table i'm
stoned to the gills i got like a
thousand milligrams of edibles in me
and i look down and what do i see tater
tots oh it's like a dish full of tater
tots with like a turkey sandwich perfect
it was a turkey sandwich with that gouda
cheese when it melts oh
oh yeah and i got that and i'm like i
looked around for cameras and [__] and
i'm like [__] it i'm clipping this and i
picked up this had to be four or five
years ago i i practice not to be a thief
but from time to time i gotta work the
muscle because it's there
i picked up the tater tots and i took it
and there's in the green room they have
a bathroom
so i actually i was so high that i
thought they were gonna find me so i
went in the bathroom and started eating
the tater tots
red it was a red sauce
and the red sauce is delicious and i'm
high and i'm not even dipping one i'm
getting four at a time and dipping them
in the sauce i got sauce all over my
fingers i got sauce all over my face and
the next thing you know the waitress
comes in
and she goes oh my god i've been looking
for those did you take those i go i
don't know somebody just put them in
here
come in here by mistake and i thought
they were the other headliner she goes i
don't worry about it you can have it
she's going to ask you a question what
did you think of the ranch dressing and
i go
ranch dressing i go that's not ranch
because it was red she goes to sriracha
ranch
wow oh sriracha ranch i love that oh
[__] delicious yeah delicious
you're like you're like on that scene on
barfly where where
where a [__] uh mickey roar gets the
sandwich and the guy goes he's like a
goddamn seagull here goes a sandwich i
love that [__] film
i have watched
3 000 movies over the pandemic yeah new
and old and i was just thinking about
that movie dear dad listen
they have played everything
the last two years on tv except two
movies yeah i sit there every night
waiting for two movies
barfly
and apocalypse now oh
[__] they have not played that for the
last two weeks at night i was so happy
because i was sitting there and i had my
choice between the wolf of wall street
or boogie nights are you [__] kidding
me or what
i watched boogie nights three nights in
a [__] row i watched at one time
because i couldn't catch the beginning
you know how we are with the temptations
you keep missing the beginning god damn
it i always catch it when he [__] uh
is [__] the first chick the redhead
right the back that played hannibal
yeah finally one night last week i saw
he was coming on at 10 and i got to
watch the beginning when he went home
and his mother beat him up and
he showed his [__] and she goes get out
yeah i had that [__] night says god
man
talking boogie nights and i somebody was
telling me they read somewhere that
years later
wahlberg says he hopes he wishes he
never did that movie for reynolds burt
reynolds said that he hated that role
and it brought him back i didn't
understand that i didn't get it yeah
that was a you know bert reynolds
i think he was up for an academy award
on that film he killed
[__] burt reynolds every time i watch
him in that boogie nights i think of one
thing i think on the longest yard
when i would be out there about six in
the morning by myself smoking a number
and bert would come out with a hat on
with like the prison jacket that they
were in the prison with his hands in
there and he would walk because it would
be like cool in the morning he would
come up to me and go what are you doing
well you know it looks like i'm [__]
doing
and he would go let me see let me smell
it and i would just put it up to his
lips and he would go
and he would walk away
i don't think he got high like he never
got high he's too old and he's been
there done that that [__] guy he
didn't give a [__] he was great he was
great
he was a great old man he really was
when i looked at him that first time in
the longest shot i'm like i
i hope when i'm that old i'm that
[__] cool yeah he was strong
he threw me around one day like a
[__]
like a doll
whoa there's a scene in the longest yard
where he's throwing me around and that
was real he was i couldn't even control
myself i couldn't [__] breathe he had
me buy the helmet and [__] and he's
[__]
face masking me i don't have like a dead
burt reynolds dude i love to
deliverance oh my oh my god
come on
oh my god that's such a wild [__]
movie oh it makes you scared of banjo
you hear banjo you just run
i remember the first time i saw that
i left i was a little disturbed
yeah i'm not gonna i think i saw that
movie a little too young you know saying
that
i was just attacked i saw the exorcist
as a young man yeah i saw a bunch of
movies as a young man but that movie
there's a couple movies that disturb me
i still love the movies you know death
wish the rape scene disturbs me there's
you know i don't have time to analyze
all the [__] movies that disturb me
but listen when a movie disturbs you
that's good
yeah when something disturbs you when it
gives you that reaction that's not the
reaction that you want but it's a
reaction yeah yeah it's like when i
listen to merciful fate you know king
diamond the first time i was like this
is scary man i was actually like i think
this is real satan music because i was
young you know
he comes on
the devil you're like oh [__] i haven't
heard that [__] in years first time i
put that somebody put it on for me one
time and i was done i think it was in
silver lake the home of that [__] yeah
that's where they invented that [__]
music in silver lake silver like devil
rock i'm telling you after they killed
[__] sharon tate they [__] sat
down charles manson in the quartet
and made that [__] killer rock how
about did you watch that
uh it was on again last night and i put
it on
i was trying to write something on the
computer and i put it on and turned the
volume off on it and it was talking
about that
that part that rick james had moved he
was a young musician he moved to
california with his wife yeah at the
time
and his first party was he got an invite
to sharon tate's house the night that
charles manson killed her he was
supposed to be at that party
but he had a headache he told his wife
he was gonna lay down the next day they
woke up
and they saw that uh manson had killed
all those [__]
oh god rest their soul i shouldn't even
call them [__] either damn [__]
it i went to see duncan one time and on
the way out he goes can i show you
something i go yeah he goes come on i'm
gonna show you the sharon tate house oh
yeah i nearly shipped my pants when he
lived up there he lived like a block
away from where they did i guess they
rebuilt the house
and they changed the address
yeah they did the numbers
so if it was like 26 mockingbird lane
it became like 33 mockingbird lane they
just did away with the address and
everything which you know
yeah you know [__] uh i believe that
dude that created like all those big
shows like full house or one of the he
he lives there now
in that mansion where they yeah up there
he built a house up there and uh you
know it's got crazy views and everything
pretty wild forget the shows he created
uh the full house and something else but
yeah he he said that on the anniversary
every year there's weirdos out front you
know
like just out there i was like wow weird
that's [__] nuts yeah yeah people
still kind of go out there and
and you know what's even nuttier that
people buy like if you go up laurel
canyon
who's the guy that lived right there
that somebody lives in his house and he
was
not the
one of those [__] creepy guys from
the 50s or 40s that was his house right
when you before you hit that little
grocery store on laurel canyon before
you hit cold water up on top there's
that little grocery store ralphie mays
to get the turkey sandwiches from
they're like 30 a piece yeah yeah big
turkey sandwiches there right there if
you because you could take that side
street
to meet you up at the top of that yep
that estate and years ago what happened
was i went to meet somebody there for a
meeting like a pitch deal
and i walked in they had to buzz me in
it was a [__] it was called paramount
management wow
and they were renting
a section out of that house it's one of
those creepy magicians
oh yeah [__] houdini
yeah
it's houdini's house so the people
bought it and they said that he had a
bunch of escape routes in there and
[__]
you open up a room a bunch of pigeons
fly out that you [__] didn't make it
to that yeah i always i always heard
that [__] like underground tunnels to go
across the street and [__] he has a
bunch of creepy [__] over there listen
when you get that much money
you know it's like when who's the dude
who lived in the hotel
in vegas
oh howard hughes howard hughes you know
those [__] dudes
they become so eccentric and they stay
in
yeah like they [__] stay in one of
those smoking jackets on
and they just think of ways it's like
when you put a kid in the timeout it's a
waste of time because he's thinking
about things to be bad you know what i'm
saying yeah it's the same thing with him
they sit in that house they got so much
money
and all they think about is [__] you
know destruction or whatever the [__]
they think about so
building tunnels and
sacrificing midgets whatever the [__] is
in their agenda for that week
axel rose style man you never see that
guy he's just stuck in his pad man you
never see him out he's not like hey axel
was at the movies or axel went to a show
this weekend or nothing you just don't
see that guy you know there's dudes that
don't go out it's a trip you know like i
was thinking about uh alex van halen in
my entire life of being out every night
in los angeles concerts backstage comedy
shows restaurants everything i have
never ever seen alex van halen once
which is wild you know
did you see eddie a lot i saw him here a
couple times like at uh heaven and hell
concert the sabbath uh heaven and hell
and i saw him at like namm show or
something but
never ever saw alex you know it was wild
like he never jams with anybody
you know nothing it's it's it's a an
interesting uh he must be like kind of
like real private and introvert or
something you know
you know it's pretty weird that i've
spoken like
you don't see a lot of people out
there's people when you do what we do
for a living you're out at night
you're out you're out at night in the
daytime you're creating you're using
your creative juices whatever the [__]
but at night you're out
i think it comes to an age like i've
read a ton of music books like about
bands
i really like when they talk about tours
on their bands you know yeah you know
i got
black sabbath i got [__]
zeppelin i you know i got all these
books about music and what i enjoy the
most
when they talk about is touring
yeah i really like the touring the
touring styles you know
i remember reading books and you feel
like a [__] loser like these bands
would do a minimum
a minimum of a year
yeah away from home
yep nobody cried nobody missed their
kids
nobody missed their wife
nobody missed nobody
nobody missed [__] nobody
now who goes out for a year straight no
one
no one you know guns just went out for
nine weeks it seemed like [__] two
years they were doing three shows a week
yeah but think about it who [__] goes
out
for a year anymore yeah
that's crazy right
i remember when gnr you know appetite
hit i think they were out for three
years three years three years three
years three years but you're young
you're stupid
they throwing money at you you fulfilled
the [__] [__] right yeah yeah you know
it's your first three years you know
they did they did those uh welcome
i'm gonna tell you something
for me
like as far back as i can remember bands
like yeah you heard i heard of rumors of
led zeppelin
you know i'm saying like i never saw
them on tv but i still remember guns and
roses like winning a grammy or something
yeah and being like an award show
and they were [__] lit
oh yeah i say that but they're out
they there [__] hammered
and i bet when they walked off that
stage and when they went home they were
so [__] happy
that they did that but years later
they saw a video of that and they were
like
what the [__] were we thinking we were
young dumb and full of [__] and we went
there and we [__] you know got
hammered
we drank everything and the same thing
goes with comedy listen my
you gotta you gotta remember let's be
honest you know i don't want to be a
hypocrite from 91
to 2007 when i went on the road it was
to do cocaine yeah i mean how the [__]
of my lion tiger yeah it was great i was
getting better as a comic
but it was the [__] party look at the
evolution of all these bands they look
at guns they start out like [__]
killers
duff lost his kidney exploded or his
liver exploding pancreas yeah pancreas
exploded [__] i don't know
what's his name don't like dope
slash light dope but you know what today
they go out and they drink water
yeah yeah you know
and they exercise and
they make time to bring a kickboxing
coach with them and that's what we were
doing when we were touring at the end
yeah like when i was touring at the end
i was trying to keep it as healthy as
nobody was drinking
you know it wasn't when i got into
comedy when i got into county there was
still
i'm not gonna name any names but there
was 30 comics that were actually
actively partying
on the road doing coke drinking [__]
[__] whatever
now
there's nobody really doing coke on the
road no no it's a business now
there's no room for it there's no room
for it i knew when i was out there
at the level i was doing it with the
theaters i couldn't even consider i
wouldn't i haven't touched it in 14
years about to be
15 years
wow
this month
is it no 14 years 2007. wow wow yeah
it's 14 years this november
15th or something like that
yeah
that's crazy man yeah i mean you know it
comedy exploded
and
and the business was always around and
you know you'd see a couple guys still
dabbling around and they're out there on
the patio talking to somebody from
netflix
and they're like oh
okay yeah right on and they walk away
like [__] that
you're still getting [__] high
yeah like he's still getting high it's
2021 i couldn't even imagine
still [__] calling mike to pick me up
so we go get a package up in jersey city
yeah i couldn't even imagine i couldn't
even imagine what i [__] feel like
right now
you know no way could i do blow right
now man
i'm at the gym i'm eating clean i want
to live you know i was i was talking to
somebody a couple days ago i want to
live like 30 more years i want to see
how this planet ends you know
[Laughter]
i don't [__] know
i don't know about that
yeah i never leave the movie early you
know that joey
[Laughter]
that's horrible i don't know how this is
gonna end but it's not looking too
[__] good i don't even think santa's
gonna come this year because he's got no
vaccination oh he's got no vaccine card
so he's not gonna be allowed to [__] out
this year either poor [__] bastard
when can he when does he have time to go
get a vaccine that fat [__]
what's he gonna do i mean think about it
i i don't know where this is going to
end
i was telling somebody earlier today
that it's been very quiet lately
it's been very quiet it's always
you could tell
it's the quiet before the storm yeah you
come out something's brewing the last
big thing we had was chappelle they came
and went
james bond came and went
to many cents came and went everything
came and went
it's just been really quiet in chapelle
they're all talking about the movie russ
did alec baldwin do it
yeah
did alec baldwin do it what the [__] is
going on everybody's talking about rust
but nobody's thinking about what look at
monday what happened with new york city
they let all the fire department the
cops and the
whatever people garbage people
so they got a whole
gap over there i don't know how they
could be letting people go you know i
mean
at the end of the day it's your [__]
body whatever you want to do with it do
it if you want to put the vaccine in to
go if you don't
[__] you do you know i don't give a [__]
what people do like i don't give a [__]
and i'm talking to people and like you
know what we ain't getting a [__]
booster
they already got us for two shots and if
we give us this booster that means every
six months we're gonna have to go back
in for a [__] shot until
they you die from this [__] thing so
i ain't mad at anybody i just want
everybody to be [__] happy listen to
music
smoke your pot do what you got to do and
go see dean delray that's it yeah come
see me
band oregon and portland do it you know
i was thinking about you the other day
how lucky of a comic you really [__]
are because we did some great work
together
correct but we've been doing like
mid-range stuff you know like chicago
data and then you go out with bur
and you get the chance to do arenas and
[__] red rocks and all these [__]
different things
and then you're you so you get a chance
to do comedy clubs and bars and you know
hallways and bowling alleys so you have
all the realms covered you know you go
out with marin you do a couple mid-range
theaters like i was doing
you have a great dean i'm so [__]
happy for you i'm happy you're still
living in the same apartment
you haven't moved you broke your own
record
you haven't moved in two years
in two years dean used to move times
it was funny i did red rocks with burr i
always say he did red rocks i was there
and then the next day i uh headlined in
ventura to uh i think 12 people uh
on a monday night
and it's like
hey man you gotta [__] do it all you
know what i mean that's not my crowd i
was just a visitor and was uh lucky
enough to do some comedy in front of
those people but uh i'm out there just
trying to pick them off one at a time
you know and and i know you and burr and
maren these guys are all 30-year men you
know it's it doesn't happen overnight
some people get frustrated
i'm out of here i know that it's like
well you know i love doing comedy so
whatever it is uh
i just i just need the clubs to let me
to book me and then you know i'll be in
heaven because then i can do comedy all
the time that's all i need i'm doing the
work i just need somebody to hire me
i put a name in for you a couple weeks
ago a girl called me
out of one of the clubs great lady you
know who she is and i told her you were
out there to
put you up so she called me a few days
ago in fact it was after i spoke to you
and you were telling me about
your situation at other clubs that
they're giving you a hard time and uh
she said she would contact you for a
little that's killer last quarter she
might have a little fallout in december
for you so i'm down i'm over here trying
to brother i appreciate what you're
doing
i miss you i miss you big time man we
expected we gotta get out on the stage
together again man listen man i i'm just
for right now i'm just leaving it open
yeah i don't know when i'm coming back i
don't know what i'm feeling i'm
healthier i feel a lot better than i did
so
one of these nights i'm gonna be sitting
in this [__] living room downstairs
i'm gonna go you know what i'm going out
to do comedy and
everybody will hear about it i just
don't know when that's gonna be but i'll
keep you posted that's so great i can't
wait dude i can't wait to see you man
hey and you do look fantastic and you
got the best hair and uh and comedy look
at that perfect head of hair broken but
i got to go get it cut today
i'm not shooting anything which is good
so i have to color it so i want my
natural color to come back
[__] white
yeah and cocaine white that's my hair
color cocaine white cocaine white
cocaine white and uh that's it man i'm
just trying to put the p i'm trying to
age
uh gracefully yeah with no stresses and
no [__] dramas and i'm doing okay so
but it's always great seeing you it's
always great to talk to you and uh
i'm gonna strap a pair on one day and go
get some tacos 1976 with you oh god i
can't wait and we all miss you at the
comedy store big time man
76 all the time
and what's that you're still getting two
tacos a day keeps the doctor away dude i
go to 1986 86 like it like it's a dealer
you know what i mean i ride around two
each day i go oh god i gotta get a taco
and i had his head right over there man
i bring gertie the dog she sniffs around
for ground scores
some [__] dropped uh carne asada ah
[__] carne asada over there is good i
haven't even the mexican food here is
terrible oh yeah i went to two places
terrible but there's a place down in
freehold i'm gonna check out yeah next
week when i go to the doctor's office
dean delray i love you you need
something you call i love you dude so
much you're the greatest for your time
thank you for being my definite guest
every 90 days it's you and rudy
i've had you on 90 days on any podcast i
did i gotta have you i miss you i miss
you say hello to bill for me and mark
and uh the crew and we'll talk in the
next couple of days buddy candles lit
stay black all right you bad
[__] i hope you enjoyed my
little tata tay with dean delray
we got off the subject we did a couple
[__] crazy things but it was just a
wednesday morning podcast for you
[__] thank you very much for
all the support you give us thank you
for supporting dean delray on this
patreon and whatnot you guys have been
great to dean and i can't tell you how
great you've been to me i'm over here
staring at this freezing bomb going
jesus christ that's a [__] monster if
you want a bong like i said freeze pipe
[__] suckers
listen i want to thank everybody i want
to thank you guys for watching and for
always being in my corner i want to
thank the ice cream shop
for supplying us with the best wheat on
the [__] planet
laughing gas
um you know packwood's got the [__]
blunt that's killing [__]
you do what you need to do i love you
[__] have a great weekend i'll be
back monday morning
tip top magoo and now
for a word from my [__]
sponsors jack what's happening but you
bad [__] the joint
was brought to you by stamps.com looking
the holiday season's upon us you're
going to be mailing a lot of stuff you
want to have stamps.com if you got kids
and work and a busy schedule you'll only
be running around back and forth
to the post office i love stamps.com
i've been with them for close to 10
years 15 years
they bring the services the u.s postal
service and ups
right to your door you're going to print
any official postage for any letter any
box any package anywhere you want to
ship
listen going to the post office instead
of using stamps.com
is like taking the stairs when the
elevator is right there you don't need
to do it stamps.com you get exclusive
discounts on postage and shipping from
usps and ups
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup that's it or drop it off whatever
you want no more traffic no more waiting
in lines no more people breathing on you
you take the confusion out of shipping
if you're not with stamps.com
you're slipping sign up right now with
promo code joey at stamps.com
right now stamps
dot com you're gonna get a four-week
trial free postage and the digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
what you're gonna do is just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and to code joey
it's that easy stamps.com you'll never
go to the post office again and you'll
have more time for the things you enjoy
stamps.com
pressing code joey for the special offer
oh oh this saturday night live from new
york city
from the garden it's usman versus
covington round two [__] the
nigerian nightmare against chaos in the
octagon again let's see what the [__]
happens
listen close because uncle joey's got
something for you you ready for this you
bet five hours in the main event the ufc
268 and draftking's gonna throw you 200.
joey what are you talking about what are
you talking about
five dollars when's your deuce
[__] did you hear that new
customers just spent five hours on
either fighter and went 200 miles and
free bets listen to me dk is great i
love draftkings from the social media to
the profile i'm over on the social media
so if you could friend me we could
[__] on there see what you're
betting see what i'm betting you got
basketball you got hockey you got pro
football college football you got the
bowls coming this is the time of the
year you want to be with draftcut.com
and don't get me starting the casino
blackjack poker live dealer come on guys
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
best of all you can withdraw your cash
whenever you want download the draftking
sportsbook app today and use promo code
joey throw down five dollars on the ufc
268 main event and win 203 bets if your
fighter wins it's that easy that's code
joey j-o-e-y this saturday night at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc i got
some rules for you ready and i don't
like rules either but they're easy rules
you got to be 21 old
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit with a
dollar wager required don't be showing
up with a quarter and [__] cocktails
one
deal per customer don't be [__]
greedy because we'll catch it
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
call 1-800 gamble if not head over to
draftkings and get the [__]
party started and if gambling ain't your
thing
guess what is the daily fantasy download
the daily fantasy app from sport
draftkings or the sportsbook app the
joint is also brought to you by freeze
pipe you guys know i like my
[__] reefer i smoke it with a
paper pipe glass an apple
with freeze pipe that's [__] home
sweet home
be a man and use a bong that's smooth
with every hit
for years i told you guys in colorado i
would fill the bong up with
snow and smoke it and then you eat the
snow and you get really [__] up you
don't need to do that no more with
freeze pipe you get an ice cold hit
every time the pipe comes with a
detachable chamber [__] tremendous
you freeze it beforehand when you're
ready to spark up
the smoke passes through the frozen part
and it cools as the smoke
cools down the smoke as you inhale it
it's like putting ice cubes in your
throat and smoking or putting ice cubes
in your bong and smoking but this is way
better it's non-toxic and it freezes
faster than water and it stays frozen
for a long time you know i smoke a lot
it's frozen solid freeze pipe cools down
the smoke by hundreds of degrees let me
tell you something your throttle thank
you i'll thank you now whether you hit
the pipe the bubbler the bung or the dab
they got it all
and i could vouch for the pipe the
bubbler and the bung they're [__]
tremendous
if you can smoke from it freeze pipe
makes it so do me a favor
go to freezepipe.com again that's
freezepipe.com
pressing code joey and save 10 off
your first order it's that easy
get your bong pipe or bubbler today
uncle joey sent you it's [__]
tremendous it hits like a mule that's
the freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10 points
go deep in the murky waters with freeze
pipe i want to thank freeze pipe i want
to thank draftkings i want to thank
stamps.com i want to thank
me [__] undies zip recruiters
liquid iv
for having our back this week but most
importantly i want to thank you guys for
always being here i love you
have a great weekend and the joint will
be back monday morning
tip top magoo i love you [__] savages
stay black
[Music]
you